[Music]
foreign
PhD cosmetic chemist and owner of purple
hair today I'm going to be talking about
10 Hair hacks that changed my routine
I'm pretty lazy with my hair care I'm
really bad at sticking to routines so
these won't be high effort hacks they're
things that you can do quite easily they
range from cheap to expensive so
hopefully there's something in here that
makes a big difference for you don't
forget to like And subscribe let's get
into it crocodile Clips I don't know why
it took me 30 years to discover these
they're called crocodile or joined
eclipse and they have this cool
mechanism that expands to grab a big
chunk of hair or whatever else you need
to grab I don't know your life I have a
lot of heavy hair so I've just had
Decades of weak little Clips struggling
to hold onto my hair and maybe I just
didn't love myself enough to look for a
solution but one of these will just
clamp launch more than half my hair with
no dramas these cost less than a dollar
or two depending on how fancy you go I
use system for everything hair related
apart from clipping my Fringe I used
them in the shower on wet and on dry
hair for treatments for dyeing my hair
clipping up my hair when it's really hot
and I don't have to leave the house so
no one has to see my great style I use
one for clipping a towel around my
partner's shoulders when I did his
quarantine haircuts I've even used them
for clipping my clothes back during
videos and clipping back curtains I
would recommend getting rubberized ones
that aren't too smooth because they grip
hair a bit better and they're also
easier to hold on to when they're wet I
would also recommend getting some with
some sort of texture on the finger grip
so they don't slip out and launch across
the bathroom when your hands are covered
in conditioner learn from my fail my
hair used to snap teeth off core Clips
all the time this is a highly
recommended quality of life upgrade
treat yourself to a one dollar clip
cornstarch as dry shampoo I know a lot
of people love how convenient dry
shampoo is but I found that the sprays
can make my scalp feel really irritated
and a lot of the scents are just a a bit
too heavy for me but I do have a fringe
and oily skin which means it gets gross
and greasy and I just start looking like
I never grew out of my nine-ish Nails
phase which is kind of true I did use a
dry shampoo that was like a Shaker once
and it turns out the main ingredient was
starch I couldn't actually find it again
and then one time I was putting on my
translucent powder which is stash based
and I thought what if I just dust it on
my Fringe and it worked the cheaper
version is just using cornstarch from
the grocery store with a fluffy brush if
your hair is dark then it can look a
little bit gray but once you brush it
and like Pat it down a bit it goes away
maybe try it out first on a day when
it's not right before an important event
some people also use it at night I
actually do this a lot of the time
before filming like today when I haven't
planned my schedule well enough to have
a nice clean Fringe I guess a sub tip
here is don't use dry shampoo too much
and stop if you get any saws or
breakouts dry shampoo doesn't entirely
replace actual shampoo and too much Gunk
and build up on your scalp just isn't
very good for it I think this is
actually the reason some people say
particular products are making their
hair fall out on that note try
shampooing only your scalp and only
condition below your ears this is a tip
that I think most people already know
but if you don't this has been
completely life-changing for me the idea
is basically the hair near your scalp
doesn't really need conditioner it
already gets a lot of oil from your
scalp which is actually why it needs to
be shampooed it's also less damaged
because it just hasn't been around for
as long it's not old and bitter yet so
it's still pretty smooth plus most
modern shampoos have small amounts of
conditioning ingredients in them like
polyquatoniums these leave a very light
protective coating on your hair that can
smooth it out protect it against more
damage also reduce static so unless your
shampoo is making your hair very squeaky
it's probably got some conditioning that
should be enough for most people's Roots
so conditioner near your scalp might not
really be adding much to your whole hair
experience but it can cause build up on
your scalp and make it irritated now
with the length they're far away from
your scalp so they don't get much oil
the main reason your hair gets dirty is
because of all this oil and all the dust
and dirt that sticks to it like a really
gross cold I'm really sorry I am not
having a good analogy day today so it
might not actually need to be cleansed
with shampoo and this obviously doesn't
apply for shampoos with other functions
like purple shampoo so for most people
directly shampooing the lengths just
dries them out and it can make them more
damage without that much payoff with
cleaning the shampoo that trickles down
as you rinse can be enough plus hair
conditioner actually has cationic
surfactants that can do a bit of
cleaning you might still need more
shampoo if you use a lot of styling
products and you might need more
conditioner if your hair is a bit
rougher at the roots but for a lot of
people I think this is worth trying my
scalp used to get so much buildup and
irritation before I stop putting
conditioner on it plus you end up using
less products so it costs you negative
money reverse conditioning if you need
even deeper conditioning you might want
to try reverse conditioning this is
where you put conditioner on the length
of your hair before your shampoo and
then shampoo focusing on your scalp then
you rinse everything out and add a
little bit more conditioner if you feel
like you need it the idea is that the
conditioner will protect your hair from
the shampoo so it's like a more intense
version of the half shampoo half
conditioner tip microfiber towel they're
towels that have very small fibers so
they have a large surface area and that
means that they can suck the water out
of your hair much faster than a regular
towel my favorite towels for this are
the aqueous tiles I've been using these
same towels for about six years ever
since they sent me a bunch for a
responsive posts full disclosure but I
still use the same lines because they
still work really well and I haven't
tried that many other options I did try
some cheaper ones that I got at hair
expo but they just didn't work as well
and they had that thing where they sort
of clung to your fingers and just felt
really icky Vanessa of goals to get
glowing tested a bunch and she found
some cheaper options that work great she
reviewed a bunch of turbans which are a
really handy all-in-one option but I
actually prefer the regular towels
because I like being able to control how
the ends get twisted because my bleached
ends are really fragile so I put the
towel around my hair I squeeze it a bit
to soak up the water and then I wrap the
towel around my head and keep the whole
thing in place using you guessed it a
crocodile clip these are also a lot
lighter than a traditional Chow so I
don't get a crick in my neck when I move
my head around and it doesn't Lurch off
my head and rip my hair out nape
undercut this has made such a huge
difference for me like I said I have a
lot of hair so one day I just decided to
cut off about a third of it it's not
really noticeable when I have my hair
out or in a low ponytail and most people
don't actually realize I have one but it
has made a huge difference it is so much
faster to dry my hair when my hair has
wet my head is a lot less heavy I also
used to get a whole bunch of knots when
the strands coming from like the base of
my neck would rub against my back so all
of that's gone and it is a lot cooler
during summer also I had so much hair
that when I left it out with our styling
and I looked a bit like grug and just
violently hacking off a whole bunch
underneath actually gives it a more
manageable shape my biggest worry about
this used to be that I would need
someone to help me shave it all the time
but I found these Clippers that are
actually really quite easy to use by
feel it's really hard to cut yourself on
these so I can mostly keep it shaved
just by feeling where to shave and I can
almost always do it without accidentally
cutting off a whole bunch of long
expensive hair every time I accidentally
cut some off I think about how much it
cost to bleach it it's something like
one cent per hair it's not super neat
around the edges because I do try not to
get any of that long hair so I sometimes
get someone to help me neaten it up but
I don't really wear my hair up a lot so
all of that shame is hiding up near the
top hair dryer with features that you
want I'm really sorry I hate hacks that
I just like buy this expensive thing but
this made a really big difference for me
getting a hairdryer that had the
features I wanted there are a lot of
hair dryers out there and my balance
probably aren't the same as yours so if
you spend a lot of time drying your hair
I really encourage you to do your
research and don't just buy a hair dryer
that someone else recommends unless it
does match your wants too I've tried a
lot of expensive hairdryers but this
Panasonic one just kind of blew my mind
I did do a sponsorship with them for
this hairdryer but this video is not
sponsored and I have no obligation to
mention it but I am because it did
really change my mind about hair dryers
so the things I really like about this
the nozzle is designed to create an
airflow that separates your hair out so
it dries faster so you don't have to be
like constantly spreading your hair out
with your fingers I mean I still do it
when I dry my hair but I have to do it
less which sounds like it doesn't make a
big difference but it does it has a
scalp function which is a setting that
goes pretty much as hot as you can get
it without burning your scalp I'm sure
it's too hot for some people but it is
pretty much perfect for me and so I can
zone out without burning my scalp or my
fingers it feels really light it's
really well balanced so there's no wrist
pain I highly recommend doing this with
any hairdryers that you might want to
buy I'm not quite extra enough to pack
this with me on holidays but every time
I'm using a hotel hair dryer and my hair
is going everywhere and slapping me in
the face like hot wet noodles and I'm
burning my fingers I'm reminded of how
good this is DIY colored hair
conditioner if you have brightly colored
hair like mine it's generally done using
semi-permanent dyes these Fade Out over
about seven washes and they don't damage
hair so you can change your hair color
all the time and it's quite fun the
problem is it washes out and when it's
really faded it tends to look a bit bad
so you have to go get it re-dyed a lot
or Diet yourself at home I started off
dying it myself at home every second
weekend it would take a couple of hours
but I got sick of that then I realized
that you could buy colored hair
conditioners that deposit a bit of dye
on your hair every time you wash it and
then after using those for a bit I
realized in this like year of realizing
stuff I could just make my own in any
color I wanted with a conditioner that I
liked you just mix the semi-permanent
dye into the hair conditioner now this
isn't entirely risk-free because when
you make your own there is a chance that
you'll mess up the preservative system
and end up with mold growing in your
product it is relatively low risk
because it is a wash off product and
it's a hair product that doesn't stay on
your skin for long but I would still
recommend not mixing up too much at a
time I only mix up about enough for a
week and I make it a bit darker than I
need and I mix it in with my regular
hair conditioner in the shower right
before using it although to be honest
that's usually because I'm bad at mixing
the right amounts together so there is
an upside there having this also means I
can wash my hair every day which is what
my scalp likes without worrying about
the color ever fading too quickly use
conditioner as a hair mask you probably
don't need a separate hair mask hair
masks usually have the same core
ingredients as a conditioner but the
main difference is they're usually
thicker so they stay on your hair more
easily so if you have a conditioner that
works well for you you can use it as a
mask it probably won't stay as well on
your hair in the shower though because
of all that extra water you can try
wrapping your hair up in cling wrap or a
plastic shower cap like a little
dumpling to keep it all together and
then clip it with a crocodile clip I
swear I am not being paid by big
crocodile clip silk pillowcase I don't
really believe in silk pillowcases at
first I thought they were a bit of a
gimmick and people just like them
because they felt nice but I've actually
found that since I started using them I
could really tell when I didn't use one
with the silk my hair doesn't end up
quite as crunchy when I wake up compared
to Cotton or linen I think that maybe I
wiggle my head around a bit when I sleep
and my hair gets rubbed into the pillow
and then when the pillowcase is a bit
more frictiony then it tends to put
kinks in my hair these these Kinks make
my hair feel crunchy and they don't
really go away until I wash my hair it
tends to be worse when I go to sleep
with damp hair and it still does this if
my hair ends up stuck behind my back
against my regular sheets I also really
like using silk scrunchies it means the
hair can slide around a bit so the hair
strands don't pull as much on my scalp
and make it sore these are also really
good for sleeping in I have to sleep
with my hair in a ponytail otherwise it
starts spreading and trying to colonize
my partner side of the bed it's a
problem watch out for Mi and MCI these
are pretty common allergens these days
about 1.5 percent of people are allergic
to them a lot of people don't know about
them and they're actually kind of hard
to avoid I am personally allergic to
them they give me a really itchy and
irritated scalp with bumps and pimples
and annoyingly they are actually super
common in shampoos most anti-dandra
shampoos I looked at actually had them
so if you feel like your scalp gets
really grumpy with particular products
it might be worth checking for these and
seeing what happens when you stop using
products with them this family of
preservatives is also in a lot of
laundry detergents so if I use the wrong
one I get super itchy when I put on my
clothes and it always takes me a couple
hours before I remember I have an
allergy so that would be another hint
and of course you can go to a
dermatologist to confirm or do more
testing if it actually isn't this I hope
these hacks were useful let me know if
you've tried any of these before or if
there's any hacks I missed don't forget
to like subscribe hit the notification
Bell you can also see me on Tick Tock
and Instagram more videos are popping up
around me if you want to nerd out more